- [Narrator] Since the beginning of time
(loud explosive burst)
The Wu Warlords
have brought suffering
and death to our world.
(man screams)
But 1,000 monks sacrificed themselves
to empower a chosen one to stop them.
- I've been looking for your, Kai.
You have the power of the monks.
Your strength flows through you.
The faces we protected.
- What's this got to do with me?
- [Female Character] You're
here because San Francisco
is where the path of the
Wu Warlords converge.
- I'm just a chef.
- No, Kai.
You are the Wu Assassin.
- The Wu Assassin bears a threat to me.
Which means he's a threat
to you and to Chinatown.
Find the Wu Assassin.
(combat)
- You can't just kill
the head of the triad.
He's your father.
- I have to triumph.
- [Female Character] We have to help Kai.
- Save the world.
- Whatever happens, I got your back.
We're family.
♪ Higher Brothers, Dogg Proud ♪
♪ We up in Chinatown ♪
- Chop, chop.
- You heard the woman.
Chop, chop.
♪ Who you gonna call?
Took his last breath ♪
♪ Thrilla in Manila, I'm
a killer and a chef ♪
♪ Chinatown ♪
♪ Clash him with a passion ♪
♪ Top-Notch assassin ♪
- [Male Character] I'm willing
to do whatever's necessary
to protect my pow-wow.
Even if I have to kill my own beloved son.
- You ready?
- Are you?
(intense music)
- Who are you?
- I'm a chef.
- I've seen this Wu Assassin.
It ain't him.
It's some old, bald dude.
Whoa, okay.
Stop doing that.